we want to make sure that
sending freight via container via
air freight via requested at the
individual shipment level becomes as easy as
sending an email so you have to
imagine that it is such an
established industry that the first
containers arrived in Bremen in 1966
not that long ago  ne so around 1966
or 70 80 000 containers moved
the introduction of standard containers,
funnily enough, extremely strongly
driven by the fact that only ships that
moved standard containers were
subsidized then
led to a global standard being
introduced worldwide
which now has more than 220 million
containers  moved in the 80s,
global trade was still about 30 percent of
GdP, so in global products today
it is about 56 percent, two-
thirds more than half
of
global value creation is somehow
also generated through trade and therefore, in
my opinion, felt extremely blatant
prosperity  how to expand our
collection of unicorn women then here in the
ear more podcast 28 pieces than currently
exist in Germany so 28 people who
founded unicorns billions of companies in
recent years one of them is
Michael Wachs from Porto in the logistics
business so he can explain to us
how they  global trade flows
work like this and how
you can earn so much money with it all
at once that you yourself
get a billion for a city all of this
completely in the podcast with Michael
photo with me grown up
or earlier has freights so this
year
you were seven years ago  years nothing
with french fries I have freedom
okay erm but before we get in there you
were training at BMW seven years ago
yes that was a very
short enabber I would say I
went back to my roots after my first startup konox with that I mean
if you  studied mechanical engineering in Munich,
that's a very
logical consequence, because it
was definitely
a very cool time to stop by the automotive industry for a moment,
I met very cool friends who I
still appreciate today,
but professionally, it's not the
right future for me, why not
yes, if you set up a company yourself
that I had around 50 60
employees when I left there
but only from ne that was my first
end effect infrastructure monitoring
so a sensor software combination for
high-speed trains and
to determine when the points have to be serviced
so first  The point of contact
with logistics for me
is such a corporate world and also such
a corporate career really
crashing into a wall at 200
[music]
has a total of I think 130 140
million dollars and one of
Bechtold's founders of San
micro-  systems and also the feeling
Anya Alibaba the lessons with the brothers are
still there and yes, I helped
raise it for the first two years and then I
got out, I would say, on the basis of the trunk of the state and
then orientated myself and  what was it what what
the business model was back then and
not very clear so
originally we tried to sell sensors
based on optoelectronic measuring
principle
torque sensors angle measuring sensors
so as I said I
studied mechanical engineering and
um found it very exciting at the time
somehow physical product
but of
course you're somehow competing with other
Vika companies, so really extremely well-established
German medium-sized companies that have
built ISO-certified production facilities
and we then
actually applied to the DB excelerator as a relatively spontaneous idea
and
Deutsche Bahn then just hired us
pitched this use case on the soft one and so there was one thing that
led to
another and then there was also a
product tin
for infrastructure moritoring of
industrial sensors that didn't
quite work out at the time okay so then first
company then you're out and  then
you went to BMW and then and that
used the time primarily to reflect,
so what might have gone wrong the first time,
what might he have
deserved, didn't work,
I also founded flatter with my former
fellow student from TCM in Munich,
and um, one of my
closest ones  Friends Erik muttersbach whom I
also met through CTM back then in Munich you
can come up to me
said about the little tree you ca
n't actually stay at BMW now had to
let them do something together again
and so we then
already have initial ideas together
By the way, this CDTM what you are
talking about is part of the
Munich technical universe and
more and more of the
superstar founders are coming out
e.g.
comes from there you come from there,
yes, I think they have really
achieved something unique, so there is a
merger of LMU and Theo, i.e.
Technical University and the quasi
social science University Maximilian
University of Munich and everything is really
thrown together, from
psychologist to doctor  the
neuroscientist and um finally
somehow quantum physicist so very
very diverse which is the reason for
only 20 25 students per semester
very strong focus on entrepreneurship
and that was also extremely live changing for me back then,
so not only
that I met many of my fears friends
there but also
my now fiancee and founded the
first company out of the context
and then also
started with Eric now forte back then
crass so it's kind of
a new place in Germany where he
suddenly has big reasons to come from
everyone is looking for it so how do you manage it
somehow  preparing a breeding ground where
companies like this can grow up is not
that easy in the EU it worked out in a way
like a
ball of course from Rocket and
all the early samba stories and
now there again independently actually
quite cool yes I think there are
different
basic principles  So one thing, as I
said, is the diversity of backgrounds,
you have both business administration and
IT specialists, that means the
first team can be
put together on site, the second, in
my opinion, is a very well thought-out
curriculum, yes, and the third, I think, is
people too  to bring them together
on a value level and very,
very strongly in terms of their goals,
uh, err, to build a platform
for
logisticians, exactly what you
are doing today, erm, the easiest way to
describe it is we have something like
Booking.com for global freight  built
so you can have everything that
is heavier than 150 200 kilos and
no longer taken by FedEx or DHL
exported via air or on request
and we just
discovered a gap seven years ago, that is in the global
freight industry
around 220 million containers are moved every year
the handling processes and also the
booking processes for the customer
are extremely far away from today's consumer
reality so if I
want to book a trip today Expedia Booking.com
Kayak unimed it is a matter of a
few clicks travel agencies are one  A
thing of the past, but if I
now want to import 2,000 containers a year as
Home24 or as Zalando,
then it reminds me
more of the travel agency days than of
today's normal
consumer world, and when we found that, there
was a model for that  or erm yes,
as I said Erik and I knew each other
from our studies and it was clear to us that we
wanted to be entrepreneurially active yes erm
it was always for us to build the space in the
company where employees
feel comfortable and
you really do have a meaningful purpose
follow and for us global
trade was something that of course over the
last 30 40 years how little other
things have contributed to prosperity in society
extremely exciting
subject
and in addition to erik Fabian was also
known for the hallemann in the founding team
German founders used to start
with DailyDeal  meanwhile I think I’m
traveling with a sustainability woman too,
but I took the one I know
Heilemann and Heilemann, both of them and
uh Fabi also had contacts in a
logistics industry and we
evaluated a few ideas together,
from the e-commerce marketplace for building
materials, so yes, say  sometimes
buy paving stones online
Platform to trade CO2 certificates
and this logistics idea, which also
falls out of context from
traditional logisticians,
originally came from a
larger Hamburg forwarding company
from the digital sector or the person
responsible for digital at the time, uhm,
we were just told that  this whole
industry still has to be digitized to a relatively small extent
and then we
did a little bit of the whole story and
looked at the industry because I had
no idea at all, I really
started googling forwarding in January 2016
and I've had bold ones
Nagel or several things but who
owns the containers when we get on
the ships who actually does what?
Completely non-transparent, well, no
one thinks about how
the clothes somehow come from China,
where this table here
was imported from, it just works
quite invisibly  the whole thing yes
and when we spent a bit of time on it
we just
realized is blatantly incredibly huge
industry yes somehow also
fourth largest employer within
Germany Spedition is a German
word that's
abroad and other languages ​​don't even have
the same component DHL
panapina  back then as kühne Nagel all
very German companies and at the same time
he is still somehow taken care of with fax
e-mail telephone
that chemicals somehow arrive in time
community is for
ship
furniture are imported from Asia Europe are
then somehow exported from Europe
and mechanical engineering equipment to Asia
and found that extremely
exciting and you just
started to program his website.
In the end you are
not a freight forwarder yourself and you now
actually have a new web portal
and how much contact behind it we
are actually already a freight forwarder that has
its own software  builds yes what
does that mean we offer the same
service as a Kuehne and Nagel
because we have contracts with now
i have people here and we have contracts
with the truck players
yes we have direct contracts with
train companies who work for us but then in
In the end they move the freight and we
orchestrate the whole thing and um can
Nagel do nothing else, yes,
the ships do not belong to them now,
but the booking of space on the
ships is a lot of space,
they have super entrepreneurs who then
drive around their advertising, yes, but
not all of them belong to them  Trucks, no, here
again, you have to dig
a little deeper
into this entire
value chain, so who does
n't own what, but the general
forwarding business is
a creative asset free or
asset light, except for goods areas or warehouses,
okay, that means you
somehow saw it back then and then
called kühner Nagel and others
said we would do it for you
so competitively and we would
like to orchestrate something do
you want to be there
we first thought about it okay
which customers are now using without
Service yes and now you can
somehow go through the e-commerce alphabet in
Berlin yes so from
Abi Abend Angels back then to Z like
Zalando we have
spoken
to customers about 20 25 customers with whom we
did an initial interview
tell me how it works  that actually
with you that somehow the
electric scooter for UNO yes from the factory
in shine Jenny is now coming to Berlin
who do you work with what are the
problems how do you wish that and
have these learnings documented and
then actually realized okay
that is actually a  unbelievable
black box so if I
'm such an e-commerce company today that
my goods are imported from Asia that's
really complex if something goes wrong
or comes too late then the
tolerance limit is more like plus minus
five days than plus minus a few
hours  I don't get
winter before it's relatively late and then I ca
n't really react at all and
then we thought okay.
Is there a way for forwarders
Hellmann bold and Nagel
to build a DHL solution that offers them a simple
way
proactive customer service better
visibility  and to guarantee higher efficiency in
processing or do
we actually have to rebuild it ourselves from the ground up
vertically integrated and
that was the solution in the end
that he said hey now somehow uh
to sell software to companies
that maybe didn't even understand
that they did  then have problems it
's relatively tedious but how cool would
that be if you just set up a forwarding company
that's five times more efficient,
i.e. can handle five times more bulky things
than he does for Kühne and Nagel it's
quite a lot of coordination and
communication effort in the backend and
at the same time more or less  offers such a
plug and play software solution in the
front end for the customer with
what can control supply change
Competitors of yours yes okay that means
the gentleman bold here in Hamburg yes yes
himself known one of the richest Germans
HSV with ten
he already has a bit  discovered in the
neck or something he was certainly
busy with us but I did
n't have one okay but okay that
means that's where he actually goes in that's that's the
same our goal is uh
but to build up global management of the
logistics company or
customer a better event  and at the
same time we as a company
can achieve greater efficiency
by automating and integrating all processes in the backend, the
communication coordination with the
with the container shipping company
with the terminal in Hamburg with the
terminal in China, to the extent
that significantly less
manual effort is required and therefore
also  fewer mistakes happen and
you have that, so to speak, there are non-specialists because
somehow you fumbled into it and
worked into it and then simply
won customers from the Berlin
access at least and then you
convinced them to test with you and then
it started,
yes, I did  I left BMW back in January, then I
moved to Berlin in February March, then we
spent six weeks building a tablecloth
and built a first mockup video of what it
looks like,
then we went to Hamburg to
pitch this idea to Burkhard Schwenker, among others  and showed the video
or the head of Roland Berger, a well-
established Deutschland AG consultant, I would say,
and um then he sat here
in his office in Hamburg, we
pitched this idea and then he first put
his feet on the table here and smoked
a cigarette  kindled mean
I've been telling people here for 10
years that they should do it this way and
we've done it now in six
weeks I'm there yes and then
we got a bit of support from
uh the industry corner and yes
then we felt  confirmed that it
's the right idea
and on the day
I quit BMW, I
met my former boss in the country canteen and
told them a little bit, hey, we want to
do Booking.com for containers here
and that  is now the big idea
and he smiled at it a bit at the time
but said yes he just
ordered a new fixie bike for his son from a Hamburg company
Hamburg company they definitely need something like that
so I ran out of the canteen and
the uh Sven  Hoffmann
founder of borbelo via LinkedIn
means if we have to
talk has a solution for you we
sent his phone number a few hours later and then
I worked on the support for three months and
he then had the first one two weeks after
this conversation
Booked a container with us,
okay, how much does a container cost with you, uh,
that has
changed a lot in the last few years. Back then it was about
1200 euros,
of which we say we take ten percent of the take
rate for the organization and and
and the handling,
yes, and then your life went  at the end
of the take so from the commission
or let's try on the container
price and 10%
.  around between 10 and 20
percent depends on whether it's
air or rail freight and um also
what volume that's okay but for
me a nail makes it just as much
more
yes in the end the question is
what purchasing conditions do you get so
volume and scale makes  in any
case a very big difference and at the
same time how strongly you can
convince the customer to stay with you
even if you have a slightly higher price
on the fact that the whole summer Anton user
experience runs much easier
and error-free with you and who then does
the transport in the end  yourself so who is
then who drives because the stuff really
gets across so we now have an
office in Kinder with
around 140 people who correspond
with the production company from now for
example is a Hoffmann from say okay
um when are the drivers going to be
finished and with that
We have commissioned colleagues in Gengen in
truck companies to
pick up the container. It is taken to the port.
Then we have a
contingent of tobacco, so to speak. Then it is
shipped on the ship from hapag-loud. We
automatically receive information from the
system when the container is open  was
loaded onto the ship were then
the ship leaves the port check
that we then know almost as far as Hamburg
when there will be enough hamburgers when is it then
unloaded in the Eurogate or Haller Terminal and then it is sort of
reloaded onto the truck and these are
different companies that
we work with  then correspond, so to speak, to
ensure that these transitions
run seamlessly, the documentation
is correctly and completely available in good time and the whole thing is then
presented to the customer in such a way that
it is comprehensible and he
can also intervene proactively in what is happening,
we have had to do that for you in recent years
too  gigantic I mean
grown a lot but I
think to myself I don't think Hamburg is
interesting after all they had to be saved a few
years later then
Hamburg bought Mr. bold yes
I think so too um and now I think they had one
last year  Earnings are in the
order of 20 billion, so we're
talking about
20 billion, and I think the city of
Hamburg is happy because 5 or 6
billion alone, special
or dividends, so to speak,
special revenue flows into the city
instead of tax money,
so that means you've
earned well there because  if you say that you
always surfed along as a percentage
it was just a boom phase so I'd
say the harvest wasn't all fat
with us and uh Haba or
other global container
shipping companies like Mask or even you
moderately were somehow uh in the
driver's seat  had the capacity which
became more and more expensive so number so much was
bought in 2016 there was
the big container crisis
in China has grown 89% here the
ships were full and for such a bike
without ships life is
worth nothing because that means were  more
ships ordered and 27 25 16 all of a
sudden a lot of
ships came onto the market at the same time there were
over capacities the prices
fell on a yes such a big
hamburger later mine back
then almost somehow had to put $50 in a
container like that in  someone
takes them with you back then it cost a few hundred euros
there was yes that was the time
Hapag people suddenly
had problems and just went in
22 Kobold and then over the whole
course in combination with crises
like the canal blockade yes or
good sir
10-15% of all global flows of goods go
through this bottleneck and suddenly
nothing worked for two weeks and
we were suddenly $20,000, which
was 20 times the price in that time  and um,
that was certainly an
advantage for us at times because the per unit
results were better, but it was also
extremely difficult to be able to grow with customers
who all had extreme demand,
but I mean everyone
felt a little bit that the Playstation 5 was coming
a few weeks  later or not at all yes
the sofa was sold out the linen
curtains at Zara Home were no
longer available yes well there were many examples
at the time of people sitting at home and
spending money on everything that
somehow made
the living room a bit more pleasant
and  was a bit more fun outside
and it was difficult to
grow there, but he has relaxed to some extent, yes,
now I think there is
a bit of a hangover after this
phase,
where of course the ships now
have significantly more capacity free and
of course the big question remains  so
how much will the consumer
deal with the uncertainty that currently prevails in the industry in the economy unless they are asking straight away
one can assume that next year
tobacco people will not tell you a record result
that is not in the can not be
difficult to assess how the results
from Hamburg but I think
that the external effects that have
experienced these 20 20 21
tires will certainly be significantly less strong,
yes, let's say 22 or 21 or
we don't usually talk
about it publicly, nothing at all but 100 million
plus or yes in any case  which now
has an evaluation, you can read
about somehow over two billion have been
built up, so that is now
valued so highly by investors
the entire company and I think there are
already 600 million that
have flowed in, about 450 million
euros, okay, a little less, but that's
it  Ten times as much as the turnover
fell in and not from just
anyone but are now
somehow Softbank and many
large investors have,
do you feel pressure there,
um yes, I think the
good thing is that the majority of the financing
that flowed into the company
is still on the ball  decided
not yet issued at the same time is
of course already a complex industry
in which to navigate, so
I think it's now less about pure play
in the software model where the um yeah where the
low ones are clear on the levers have to be
something
where we simply have to do for a lot longer  also have to do with a lot of effects
no that was
somehow um Kobe 2020 is the canal crisis
and port bottle next in the USA 2021
2022 then the energy crisis Ukraine Russia
no so these are issues like we have
one two three our biggest
air freight partner companies were
Russian freighter airlines in Q1
last year from one day to the next
we had zero air capacity,
so to speak, so if you order the juice from a
software company today,
well, then you can
switch to Esche or Google Cloud,
but also the heck of a few weeks and
stuff like that  Happened to us and now
very, very regularly but nevertheless it is
of course already somehow, I
mean, you can name a few other
investors, that's a
lot of money in the northstone,
just tell me a few that you know,
er, at the beginning  we um chief
supported her and cherry here that looks
round together with the family
so okay everything yes also people who
already had podcasts no so
they were maybe
here I think Jeanette from La Familia
was here before so exactly no are
super happy  with the with the support
also from investors
who also happened here, for example, a person
then made the series,
er, expert, and then she is with
Softbank and the series we had
almost out of nowhere from an American
investor and and adia
is that now  then a company like that
or then companies from the rating point of
view where you have to worry
that the rating
might not hold up now because that
was also a rating that of course
came about at the time maybe that I
was basically March so
probably were  the talks
are then still in the days before the Ukraine war
and before just when you say okay
maybe that was a
lot back then and if you
look at it realistically the weather is then only what
would still impress 67
million and not more than two
years  is that a company that
could catch us or say no,
the next rating if i
need one it will definitely be
higher again
so the last question to be answered first
is actually simply not to be said
yet i think it is difficult at the moment because it is a
hard one
There are too many moving parts to make a statement on this.
If you
look at the industry in general, a
public sector is first of all everything that
concerns non-profitable tech, so non-
profitable attack companies like 80 90%,
so I think we also have
very
prominent examples  Here in Germany,
when you look at the share prices,
you can see that
something has changed
and it is the advantage of private
companies, i.e. companies that
are not listed on the stock exchange,
that you cannot follow our course on a daily basis
and when we  there is no need to rush, there is
also no pricing event, which means that the
expectations the investors had of us,
which were certainly played out again by this two-time
evaluation,
we must now first meet them in the
next few years
and now the question is okay, I think we can do
it
there  there is an extremely
high chance that it is possible but
we cannot influence many of the factors
it is of course
also partly dependent on how the
freight rates develop how the
economy develops in Germany
how do
the interest rates develop somehow and thus also
the  the look at growth companies
whose cash flows are in the future
and less
significant profits and
positive cash flows today. Freight forwarding correlates very closely
with the economy, so if
the economy is doing well it would be
logical to say that there is a lot of driving back
and forth because people are buying something
want to build something or because someone wants to build something, so
then
you're doing well and if the
economy is down, then
the freight forwarding industry is generally doing badly,
you can say yes, yes and no, well, I
think the good thing is, uh,
business is always no, so it's
always logistics
I think the question is more about
demand and supply is a very
sensitive construct, so the
whole supply in the industry is
elastic what do I mean by that at
the moment from kobit where people suddenly
wanted to consume an extremely large number of goods it is extremely difficult
to build new ships overnight, so
a ship takes about three years
and there were massive container shortages,
um
really empty steel containers, there were
far too few, then
a lot of containers were built extremely quickly, so that it is
already estimated that
the effort alone
teaching containers that are now too many in the
system to be positioned in such a way that
they do not move in the port
will lead to delays again okay um well
that means when the demand
is very high it is very difficult
to meet this demand at short notice
I just can't just do it  book quickly on the
Cloud 3 server
at the same time, but even if the
demand drops, the supply is
stable for the time being, so of course you can
actually do, the economy is already
relevant and, above all, so after
increased relevant, because not only
does the price go a bit
together  that's actually every
economic effect is
amplified by this elasticity can
say that exactly, but is controlled very
strongly by ten companies worldwide
on the supply side, which
in the end
are ten big wheels left that
are responsible for the capacity Mask,
so to speak, originally Italian
known but the bootstrap belongs to him
I think the thing is completely private
and um well I just forgot the name I
read madness the guy
somehow I must have
earned billions I think people 10
billion so only that belongs to him because
that’s crass than  would or so ne yes
could
say family is really
impressive family of entrepreneurs
that belongs to him 100% i think it was
a bit more than 10 billion but
nobody knows exactly yes but no
reports on that not somehow a
dividend stock exchange that is just so
private its Portugal  but if you
say hey, do you have the birth rap,
he wouldn't know what it means,
his part of the family doesn't have it yet,
but he's really still
in the office seven days a week, no, he
's really there with, er, heart and
soul  and that's sex is his
life so okay
that's rare in the startup industry
so okay then Italian speech
MSC is that ne that the biggest what
's still so MSC the biggest two
biggest Danish companies also to a
large extent family hand
knows very well the whole
Committed to sustainability issues and
yes then cosco shipping Chinese
company that I think is listed in the
middle 2nd place and then oats
people but people I think is also in
the top 5
seamatic French shipping company that
you still know so you should actually
notice because the containers go
then there's  somehow um
Ocean Network Express so it's
not very strong consolidation and
these 10 companies are now more or less
responsible for the supply industry
the demand as I said is
determined by the economy but since it is very
inelastic these companies have to meet
the demand for in 3 years
Prepayments can be very precise so that there is
not such an
unbalanced supply demand
situation and what relevance
now has sea containers vs flights so if you
look at the entire global logistics or freight forwarding volume is it
essentially ships or does it feel like
the flight has a role or truck or
something  I recently said about
220 million containers, so it's called
the twenty-footing unit system, so the 20-
foot containers are moved every year, that
's quite a lot, 90% of all
physical goods that we see were
or are in containers, so very
containerin would be very container  So
in the end it is yes air question is just
somehow air after this um
significantly small share so in terms of
turnover you can say similar but
in terms of volume um it was
significantly lower so 10% or something like that
probably less than 10%
50% of air freight  about
passenger plane
exactly so if you want to
do a week of culture to China next time, then he's
50% of the belly in the
Dreamliner with cargo full okay but
now somehow so no
reproach I didn't know that at the time
witnessed Russian logistics or also exciting
development during kovet there was
of course no tourism between
China and Europe 50 percent of the freight flown to date
was moved in these
passenger planes, i.e. there was
then a very large
transition to freight planes and there
isn’t anything like that  many airlines operate the
plane without such a high number of specialist machines
er freight planes and
of course we do
n't have to err that at the end of 2021 somehow at the end of 2021. Putin
now in front of the Ukraine
and then of course we immediately
broke off all err contacts and err relationships
but okay that means there you have it  then what
is not clear to me now as not an
industry expert and
we used the trucks there is
probably a whole range of clothes
yes there are also many exciting
digital company broadcasters for example
here from Berlin yes I am often asked
if we are completely deep  are but in
the end it's a very compliment Opel n
you have to say the company
somehow invests, I think, among other things,
also by the way, a unicorn
colleague we even met at a recent
event together
with the founder of the station, but you're
supplementing it then, exactly so  Sender
only does road freight, i.e.
divisions and full loads of trucks,
i.e. Munich Hamburg
40 pallets of beer and we basically
only do intercontinental and the respective
load mile from the factory to the port or
to the airport and then again from the
airport and the port to the
warehouse from where  from the respective
companies then send the goods to the
end consumer why are
all these logistics and
forwarding companies so strong in Germany
so that's just because
shipping companies there are also somehow as an
example
forwarding agency kühne Nagel and it's that warm
I think it's yes  It's already a global
business, so
it's probably also global to a large
extent.
I can't answer you exactly why it really has such strong roots in Germany,
but there really are
companies, including large forwarding companies
from Austria that really
started with stagecoaches. Companies
are more than 500 years old  old and
maybe what happened to me as a result of the
geographic configuration of Europe
it could still happen
that Germany, as well as
always strong exposures, had a very high
logistics requirement in order to then export machines
to the USA or Asia for a long time,
that was certain
All the drivers for this then of course
a bit of German DNA in the sense
of working very meticulously
may
have made a big difference, but in the
end it's um business is very, very
global, which means you're also president in the
USA, for example, we have
currently no branch in the
USA but we have 16 offices worldwide in
Asia and in Europe in Asia are always
represented Vietnam Singapore Hong Kong
and China
what do you do from these
offices then
customer acquisition i.e. of orders
or or is that just then  Coordination
both so coordination and
customer acquisition so last week I was
in our office in Vietnam
Vietnam last year 8.3% GP growth
that's really impressive what's going
on and with that Team of
25 people who work for our customers in
Germany  Coordination between
the factories and then just the ones who
help but also in the sales team,
which then sells, for example, to and running
air battle when the container
is no longer on the ship
and this this so this sale
is then web-based so that in the end
people after  google you or for
some way we say logistics and ask
Google or do you have to
reach out and address them proactively
and I can't
imagine that you
can create something online like that, yes it's nothing I would
say the small ones  Customers also come in
via online marketing and uh then book
containers themselves, but they also work a lot
with established medium-sized companies
who certainly also appreciate the personal
contact with those responsible for sales
okay that means you have to
call them yourself
okay okay uhm
yes there are  the marketing answer
or the uhm the honest so
honest answer is that at the time we
had a trademark dispute with a
US company and
it annoyed me anyway
that you always
had to spell the name on the phone and the
people is  then often just compared with the
chip shop or
exchanged them and accordingly
it was the opportunity for us on the one hand to
clarify this switch from now just transport providers to more holistic software providers including management software and a more efficient backend and then we
took the opportunity  to push it again with the RE
branding, but the trigger
was in the end doing and where are the
Heilemanns, I mean, they were
there in the early phase, now I
recently heard again that they are very busy with their
before and after engagements
and are doing there  a lot
but with you they disappeared a bit
after the build-up phase,
so we have Eric my suitcase ner
originally also played a major role in
building up Fabian Ferry’s first company DailyDeal and as a result
they had known each other for a very long time
the
most talented entrepreneurs that we
knew and who were also extremely well-known
throughout the industry and who had
excellent contacts
definitely wanted to be more entrepreneurial after they sold you the second time.
Fabi had then just um
been like her business with early  bird
and accordingly it was clear
that he would then no longer support the company two
case operatively
Ferry was still on a sabbatical at the time, I
think he also needed a break
after somehow
full throttle two years of competition against
Rockets right after his studies, certainly more than
deserved and then have  Erik and I
just started operationally, his Fabi
as a mentor and and and investor and
a few months after the termination came
to Samsun, so to speak,
the company also ran the company for a few years
as CEO,
but in the summer the
area of ​​responsibility was relatively congruent with
mine  So if you were
concerned with fundraising, sales and and and other
topics and then I think he
always
discovered his passion for lasting similarities, whether
it was through the founding of leaders
before climate action or now
the impact I found
meanwhile also as an LP
Fuchsien am very strong in investments
sustainability area and yes it has been
almost three years in the end Erik and
not the company currently
in the company
sufficiently large part so 10%
something else I think you can even
read in the commercial register but  10% is
no longer no more so we have to be
less good I mean even if it were
five if the ratings
were to grow in there now this two
billion
Internet was on our board for a long time
and he shaped this statement
a little bit more  the mass in melon
as a whole
[laughter]
I can imagine in your life
often said greetings
okay um but I mean that's
because it's naturally out of the leg
it's already too realistic for the future
that you
growing in there somehow and that it is somehow always
in the dimensions yes then
here and so everything that you
would expect in the next few years
I think we are all currently
in the phase of a
yes how should you put it new invention so
what is  the reality now no so we
have certainly been able
to experience an extraordinary time for two years
yes somehow 12% 12 years
low interestate then
unbelievable consumption francy but a lot of
simulus packages 17 trillion dollars which
were tipped into the economy in 20 20 20 21 that  were just
sick extraordinary times so
it will happen again that companies
on 100 xlaa trips probably
not ne so average for all 100 XL
means a hundred times the enderal
revenue as goodwill that's a
hundred times it's ultimately
nothing else more or less  well
that's a word no yes actual is
the turnover it's it's the the
average of all concerned companies the
stocks are more like 6.5
[music]
is now stabilizing how long
the interest rates will stay
at now so i four and a quarter
percent current US or four then
four and three quarters percent in the US
current how long will inflation stay up
now
how long will it take how long will it take it back to
normal
why is it crucial
a company's cash flows are discussed
on the interest rate and the higher  the
interest rate is worth less
but cash that the company
will generate in the future today
compared to companies that are already very
accurate today
and then today it is less earlier
it was different but if there is interest there
the money in the future was almost the same
and  uh you can always see today uh
that
uh yes many companies that are
currently having to err try to
avoid rounded price valuation by
accepting changes or unfortunately
having to lay off employees to
reduce costs and then stretch the remaining
capital a little
and I believe there is currently
no clear statement as to what the next
two years will look like. Yes, I believe
that this is definitely a phase at the moment
in which every company
is trying to position itself more robustly, in which
the concepts of profitability
and
cash flow are definitely making inroads again  also
found the voice file but it's
really cool
especially disappointing or even with a
challenge that you say okay even if
you now manage to achieve an internal
turnover of 500 million, which
would be an extreme leap
next year and then an amazing performance
you say then it's like
that then fight like that and then you would
somehow have in two and a half more or 3
billion valuation not much
more than just a short time ago you would have put so many
years of work and a whole
is that's why
it's still doing that  that you'll be back there
no less I don't think so, so
I think
if you really manage to solidly
grow into the rating that you've
somehow gotten in the last two years,
it's really an
extremely remarkable achievement, I
think it will be  many companies
that don't succeed and so why
what is it about in the end we want
to build a sustainable company
that will still be there in 10 20 30 years
that definitely
offers extremely solid and safe homes for employees and also
meaningful purpose after 700 I think we
currently have about 900 employees
what are the projects you are currently planning the
most but for the next few months
what are any projects
I am currently allowed to do very strongly around Import
Lounge in the visibility area so if
the last year and a half has been an extremely long
time  So the most important
masters spent us from such a container
import being able to communicate even better, more detailed,
more seamlessly to the customer,
i.e. to track, to
ensure quality and that is a huge
prog lounge that we will now
also be advertising in the second quarter
is a second major topic
certainly
tendering phase for many large
customers with whom we work together, they are
now allocating their annual
container quotas to the
respective partners and the third one has
just opened
in China
Logisticians, above
all, on site, this tracking is
really a feature that customers what
helps you to win orders I mean
in the end imagine as long as
the real one is there on time and the price is
right who cares when the stuff
is there are certainly customers the other
primarily have loyalty to the price and
said there are certainly also
customers who say okay, I have a
complex supply chain and whether the
container is three days earlier or
later or I potentially
pick up the container too late from the port
and thus
incur penalties  really made a
difference for me and I think after
the last two years, a lot of
customers in this area have recognized the art of
storage out of business and
are therefore also
much more robust and resilient
in terms of the supplement planning
that is then  it makes sense for you
argument and your work in there
because that ends up winning half of the
customers because you better there
the other so what's the vision of
from photo yes we want to make sure
it's shipping freight via
containers via air freight
asks at the level of individual shipments is as
easy as sending an
e-mail
so you have to imagine it is such
an established industry so the first
containers arrived in Bremen in 1966
not that long ago so in 1966
around 70 80,000 containers were moved today there
are 220
millions  Freight transported on ships or
stopped there was still no
standard for a container and the
introduction of standard containers,
funnily enough, was extremely strongly
driven by the fact that only ships that
moved standard containers
were subsidized then
led to a global standard
being introduced worldwide
which is now  more than 220 million
containers moved in the 80s,
global trade was still about 30 percent of
GdP, i.e. global gross social
today it is about 56 percent, i.e.
two thirds more than half
of
global value creation is somehow
also generated by trade and therefore in
my opinion  felt extremely blatant
prosperity so 25 years ago
when my schensen was visiting China
he still saw how people
saved the sheep and today it is
a global metropolis with over 25
million inhabitants why because their
work could also offer
is one today  of the finished
cities for electronics products and
I find that incredibly impressive.
Is it actually the
main trade route in general, from
China to Europe and the USA, or are
there other routes that
play a role for you? The largest
trailer in the world is within
Asia  So more than 30 million
containers are moved within Asia,
so from China then to Vietnam
or something like that
from children to Australia okay and then
we will be doing a few things
from Vietnam to China from India to
China so we are  also quite represented on the Inter
and then the
next one will come from China to the USA,
probably not exactly, so I think
when
I compare that whenever you
really want to become a good bakery,
it is often not enough
to just sell extremely good croissants, yes, because the
customer has  maybe different
tastes, so freight forwarders ca
n't afford to sell you just the
best croissants, but
in the end you need a
product portfolio that
covers all needs, uh, that can be
air costume transport from factoring
Japan to India or then
an expert from Europe  in the USA
and there the goal is definitely
to be represented globally in the medium to long term,
but of course it is also an
industry that you can very easily get
bogged down in and lose your focus,
and for us at the beginning it was
important to trade in as  build up a
significant volume in Europe Europe Asia,
I mean Germany is a
strong exporter, which means that you also
sell a lot out of Germany and where to do that. You then do it
accordingly, so where do we sell
most of the USA,
phew, I should actually know that it
is an export nation  yes, more on the
basis of the value of the goods than volume now,
yes, in terms of volume, China has
long since overtaken us,
so the larger number in the world mask
takes four again for every container they
bring to China,
okay, which somehow gives you a
sense for it  how much is really
sourced worldwide from some Factory China and if there is
now all this tension
around China, so you can
read about it, for example, between China
and the USA now we're talking
somehow today at the beginning of February, are there
any balloons or  there's always
something
[music]
that shoves us all at great risk,
but especially for you, yes,
that's certainly
been a topic that I've thought about a lot, especially in the last two and a half years,
and I think so too  just two
weeks ago in economis you could read we
here zero sum is the end of
globality globalization is now near i
believe that we are currently living in an
age in which
everyone is
looking at themselves much more so i have my last
12 months  Unfortunately, we have to
read more and more about geopolitical tensions
arms build-up,
most recently
Russia's invasion of Ukraine, which
has shown that, let's just say, the idea
of ​​a network of somehow
peaceful coexistence and, above all,
peaceful Europe
was perhaps naive for a while and that has an
extreme impact
act globally and um in an age when
many of the big nations, and
some especially the USA or China, are
looking at themselves much more. The question is where is Europe
and I think that's a
question I often ask myself  At the
same time I think I think there are so many
dependencies in global trade so
I think if we stopped trading
with China today the first thing that would
happen would be there are no
more medicines there are no
more antibiotics there are no more Eclipse
medicines so that would be an
incredible tragedy we  we were
able to follow a bit how it
was at the beginning of kobit it was only
about masks and now somehow
protective equipment but we were
able to follow it very closely at the time and
somehow had special planes flown in
with a police escort then from
Frankfurt Airport to the warehouse
or the  Masks were distributed,
some of these mask scammers
somehow betrayed you booked with
umpteen really some of the politicians who
later became public in the media
who asked us, we
worked together with them at the time,
but that was definitely an extremely
exciting phase  I think this emix colleague from
Switzerland who somehow
sold masks for hundreds of millions afterwards at the ministry that
was then on the slip of paper at
some logistics department of you know why must have
probably it was definitely um
extremely wild time but you have, so to
speak  So I did
n’t experience anything passively there myself, and
at the time they
must have imported more than 40 million masks to
Germany via several
companies that asked us about it,
waiting for
service providers there was a
bit like I don’t know if he
knows the film Warlords
[music]
American comedy  where the
Ministry of Defense is publicly tendering military contracts for the first time,
you have to imagine it and it
was really really wild times yesterday
hundreds of people
somehow
imported cat scratching posts from Thailand on the day
and somehow four pallets of them
a month suddenly somehow
chartered an Antonov
then  Selling 5 million masks to the police
in North Rhine-Westphalia, yes,
and accordingly, of course, the
decision was made.
It was definitely, but in any case,
looked at soberly, he has
already shown the dependence
on China extremely strongly in the small
area of ​​health care  I
mean why are there these tensions
between China and divisible why are there
these tensions also between China
and the USA in the end it goes to the chip
technology for the most
part yes if people there is just
one company in the world that can put 5 nanometer
chips per 10 in the system  Thailand
with the help of
SML in Tokyo Elektro in the Netherlands
in Japan and two other
American suppliers and everyone is
now somehow fighting for access to
this technology and erm that was
200 years ago it was maybe or
100 years ago it was about oil yes last year it
was about  it's in the gas and ten years now and
the next 10 years now maybe
great then chip technology and I
don't think that's
exactly what's
really going on there no that's a
bit rare it's about idealism
probably also ideology or a
bit like that yes  so if not not so
specific if you understand okay with the other side
tell me
what was still interesting you have
this founders patch things so
you can see that I
even looked through the profile it said it said that it
is that also want that
Buffett and and somehow Bill Gates
did it that means when you die
one day that when
a large part of your wealth is gone
that um well um I think more so
platch organizations I think that's
less waffle and and and money that's
one  Organization to which, surprisingly
and impressively, a
lot of German founders now
belong, which helps you
to donate part of your potential exhibition
and I think it's a miracle from
a company that
has also developed well in recent years that you can
certainly also go to the  very
strong part privileged and I've
already thought about how you
can give something back to society and drive the blatch
it's in organization that helps to
find the right organizations so that you can donate a
significant part of your assets
later and  That was definitely
planning, because you
also say it's just better than
inheriting that or something like that, yes, I think that uh,
everyone has the wish that their children
will be fine later on, but I think that
can be the case when you take so much  that you
no longer have to work yourself
okay so there are definitely other
ways of looking at it there are also
guests here who see it for themselves a little bit
but there are also guests
who have the feeling I know I know that
exactly but no one tells me now either
a few people I think there's just an
awful lot and there has to be
some madness yes yes well yes
I think that um I'm a big fan
of
reality and um honesty I think
I'm so honest with myself
that I certainly  Also financial to a
certain degree, but even more so
that I'm sure
that it
's a socially meaningful company that you build something
on that you can be proud of
that you somehow exploit the potential
of such a company
because I believe  in the end you need
a lot less to
live happily than you might originally
think crass crass there are other
big competitions apart from people you
know so what with you because they are
assigned over to you or what
else is there so as I said we are
primarily in  Competition to established freight
forwarders who also transport freight
yes and um DHL
DSV here from Denmark is really
established companies
who also
have their right to exist I believe
that in the end we offer very good customer service with the extremely young,
motivated team
with a high
visibility and
error probability
Basis of the integration
Automation in our system what it
is not a nail currently on the stock exchange who does
n't know it
should be around 20 around 15 15
16 billion about yes then
we know then yes there are a total of
over 25 companies in the  Logistics
that are valued at over a billion
worldwide and accordingly I think
the cake is very, very big then there is
definitely something to be had and you
yourself boldly and Nagel now have
container transport just a little more
than 3% parent worldwide or what was
that  has to do yes getting in there is
still a lot ahead of us yes everything is clear thank
you very much thank you philipp had a
lot of fun tip top